stationary points exist when when the
first derivative is equal to zero so
let's go ahead and do that stationary
points when the first derivative is
equal to zero
that's this two minus 72 on x squared
equals zero okay so when I go ahead and
try and knock this out I'm going to get
this is that okay I'm gonna multiply and
I'm also going to divide so that gives
me this or this now what would you like
me to do I'll tell you square both sides
but of course while I do that I know
that there are two square roots of will
two values that could satisfy this right
once I take the square root plus or
minus six okay aha
but remember our second step in this
whole process was note the restrictions
so one of these solutions is invalid so
I'm literally gonna say but X is greater
than zero right therefore x equals six
only please don't skip that let me
highlight it here don't just say oh I
know the restriction is in the back of
my mind I'm just going to write down the
ones that apply okay just go straight to
x equals six
that may be true you may be thinking all
that but you haven't demonstrated that
you know what's going on that there's
two solutions but one is invalid for
this reason that you said before okay so
it's a small thing but please go ahead
and state it all right question
at which line you talking about yeah yes
the short answer is no because let me
explain so what what what areas talking
about is out of here one I just say the
absolute value of whatever answers there
are okay and the reason why this is not
the case is because I could have crafted
a different set of constraints and that
kind of thing such that suppose suppose
suppose mmm so suppose my solutions out
of here end up being not not this right
which is what which is what I have but
suppose there was something like this I
don't know okay suppose that was after I
I did all my calculus and worked out
always going on that's what I got okay
well here I'm going to get two solutions
on time negative fourteen or two now
it's not just the magnitude like for
negative fourteen I can't just say I'd
like it to be positive so therefore
fourteen is where it's going to occur
that's not in the domain so I can't just
say yes this value and just make it
positive because because I'm supposed to
be positive
this is actually an invalid solution
it's not that it's the negative version
of a valid solution there isn't in x
equals fourteen over here to which it
corresponds this is the solution not the
absolute value of that so that's the
reason why okay okay so I've done my
model I've done - friction semi-finished
with calculus and we're done hmm now
what have I established so far well you
can work this out this is why your
connective tissue your words and that
kind of thing you're not many of them
are so important what have I done I've
only found stationary points right but
I'm looking for a minimum so I actually
have to go a little bit further to
establish that this is a minimum what
could I use to do that I can use the
second derivative or Eyck
would test either side for the first
review have a look at the function
there's the derivative second derivative
or first review remember I know it looks
like a question right now but it's not
really right it's not really a quick I
mean I don't have to write as a question
if I don't want to I think second
derivative is easy it's just the power
okay so to determine the nature I'm
gonna go ahead and differentiate again
so this is d squared P or DX squared the
two contributes nothing you're gonna
start doing that thing with the power so
that's going to be a hundred and forty
four X to the negative three so it's one
hundred and forty four and X cubed okay
so when x equals six when x equals six
the second derivative is what 144 on
that's two hundred sixteen isn't it two
hundred and sixteen now I could simplify
that but I don't need to I have a number
all I am interested in is not the size
but the the sign I'm just looking and
positive or negative right so this this
d squared P on DX squared is greater
than zero that means it's concave up
which is a relief because concave up
means a minimum which is what we're
searching for
okay so now I have established it's not
just a stationary point it's a turning
point and it's a minimum turning point
now I'm done with my calculus okay
so dick what's the last thing I actually
got to find the perimeter like the
question is about perimeter not the
dimensions where is it
not the dimensions that give me
perimeter okay thankfully it's quite
easy to work out if this is six and this
is six then what's the width going to be
also six are you happy with that make
sense so by the way just as a minor
point you're often asked a question like
this what are the circumstances which
minimize perimeter or minimize area that
kind of thing and you often end up with
equilateral shapes that's not a
coincidence so you'll get this quite a
bit like when you get say a very very
common one that the HSC loves to pull
out is they say there's some kind of
shape that's inscribed in a circle okay
so I could inscribe a rectangle in a
circle it would look like this here's a
rectangle and I can sort of squash and
stretch it or alternatively they might
say hey can you inscribe a triangle
inside the circle right and do the same
kind of thing and you will almost always
find it's an equilateral triangle okay
so you know if you've got your intuition
here you get to an answer yeah oh is it
an equilateral thing yeah we often get
those so no surprises there okay so just
to review the first part where you
probably ought to do the most active
thinking is you've got to create the
moil
okay if they don't give you pronumerals
you need to introduce yourself and
sometimes that's part of the question
once you've got your model just watch
out for the restrictions this is
actually the the simplest kind of
restriction there is because you get
lots of geometry problems in here and
that's like an default okay but
sometimes you will have weird other
descriptions based on time or distance
just go read the question carefully note
them before you do any calculus because
once you start differentiating and
finding things like this sort of hijacks
your brain and you forget that you're
asking a question with context do your
calculus don't just find a stationary
point make sure you
determine its nature and then make sure
you actually answer the question once
you've got a stationary point whatever
happens to me okay